I come to this video five minute game
cabeza rule from Argentina yeah let's
try French I liked my positions recently
in the French it once and a 3 mm yeah I
already got that him very recently and
yeah before I think if i'm not mistaken
um I can Black has a pretty weird bit ly
now be five and then night XD form
setting up a position with the K it
didn't it didn't materialize and this is
in true this is an interesting line
though 94 sacrificing a piece okay so
i'm probably going to prepare long
castles here and knight to e7 and g6
maybe is going to play Bishop d3 anyway
how to how to go about that
yeah maybe maybe it is an idea to to
threaten a g5 him to provoke him to play
h form this will also make him I think
twice about canceling short the g5
assume is really a threat now I think he
needs to play h form or B should be free
in tending the check I cannot afford to
run around with my king so um where this
is interesting I didn't think about that
move very a concrete way play maybe a
very good way to play hmm yeah
yeah Castle some logistics rook h7
Bishop d3 this looks more than more than
problematic hmm
wow that's really awful maybe I need to
do this even 96 am we cannot cannot can
tolerate that yeah I know the king but
what else was there okay but anyway and
now I've got Bishop 88 yes this is maybe
not so terrible if he moves the Queen
I've got g5 him so he needs to do that
the question is what now hmm I could I
could just take yeah it's not this is
probably all right
and now maybe just go into the seven
intending to take a black Winnie aid
yeah this is some this exchange has
helped me a bit okay get rid of this and
Queenie aid yeah probably this is isn't
this isn't so we're so terrible anymore
I can play King c7 and this is this is
quite ok Jack awake exchanges okay this
now is it's very comfortable the
question is how to play maybe maybe I
should prevent h5 and intent here but
should be seven with the tempo and now
here yeah yeah in fact mmm in fact I
always I already prefer black here I
have some active active play here
against against d5 intending g5g form
okay yeah but I can't do that takes h6 I
take f3 that's some pressure already
here okay c4 is not a bad square uh-huh
and now g5 yeah and important is that
attack with the sugar course so that he
cannot protect f2 anymore
I take would have taken to the Pawnee
could could just drop bag check um take
a form yep
this is the easiest and now let's
protect the second rank and I'm
attending night see form then he's got
all these we queenside bones so I'd like
to defend here the rook defense and
night see form is the move to get some
activity here against against the c3
porn yep okay check yeah I don't want
him yeah shouldn't if I could give away
e6 this is a bit tricky yeah okay not
nothing nothing else
okay that's rub everything here now he's
got he's got two points as well mmm how
to play that get the a poem going
this wasn't so great time warning
problem check
again position is ok but 15 seconds
check
grah okay maybe software is accepting a
wrong never know sometimes they do no he
rather check gets to a lost position but
nine seconds yeah but I should manage
getting getting a queen yeah pre move
mode white resigned galant but to accept
the draw then instead of giving it all
away yeah it was interesting I mean this
age six the opening is quite curious
with age six I don't know maybe it was
it was it was terrible but did know the
computer likes me like my position okay
so this wasn't wasn't yeah this is
curious the computer after night g7
gives black a clear advantage mmm yeah
the thing is white loses lotsa time and
at the end I'm are threatening g5 and
the the center is loose in fact it seems
that here I could have played g5 I
didn't think about that ah there's
Queenie 5mm I should have spent some
more time him yeah I was I was really
scared about all this with night age for
Queen age five and I was glad that be
should be eight was actually okay and
then I played it but I can't go g5 here
I I missed this tank and this wins the
house
I this is stupid hmm yeah well okay Kent
I was glad to be alive I mean this is
also was quite good but down I I didn't
use it to the fullest here the computer
gives the idea computer is completely
hey cool it wants to take this yeah it's
possible that's 93 check hmm yeah I was
I was too scared about all this and was
glad to have equalised alright thanks
for watching